implosion de la bach debussy à la
courneuve c'était le 18 février 86 et le
mesurais 185 mètres de long véritable
obstacle entre la cité des 4000 et la
ville de la courneuve aujourd'hui face à
l'espace libéré le nouveau quartier de
l'orme seul à proximité de la future
gare l'esprit de la réhabilitation peut
se résumer ainsi cassé le ghetto mais
sans renier l'histoire de la cité on
sent très attachés à leur habitat la
meilleure preuve c'est que lorsqu'ils
ont des monnaies la grande barre depuis
si il était le départ prévu
enfin projeté de démolir voilà la petite
barre les habitants sont s'y sont
opposés et ont se sont disons d'une
présentation très forte et les habitants
sont très très porteur d'un lors de leur
demande ils participent à l'élaboration
des programmes
des trouées de lumière a flambé ton tel
est le projet de rénovation de la barre
balzac
sur les 307 appartement une quarantaine
a été supprimée pour ouvrir de
véritables fenêtre sur la ville certains
logements sont transformés en duplex les
salles de bains et la cuisine sont
refaites ainsi que l'étanchéité
mais la performance technique c'est
qu'on mène les travaux alors que
l'immeuble reste habité il s'agit
maintenant de produire une nouvelle
image en s'appuyant sur l' architecture
de départ recouverte d'un acier spécial
ses découpes monumental devrait
illuminer les façades les plafonds sont
en acier émaillé de colorer ce qui va
colorer la lumière sur un des côtés de
ses fenêtres on aura l'acier inoxydable
qui est un miroir parfait qui permettra
d'abord de renvoyer la lumière en faire
plus conséquente à l'un de l'autre côté
du bâtiment et d'autre part qui fait que
le ciel sur la clé sera dans l'épaisseur
même du bâtiment et le bâtiment va se
disent ou non l'idée de masse du
bâtiment va se dissoudre à l'inter de
l'annual intérêts notionnels
le bâtiment était vraiment son ombre il
fallait quand même une découpe quand
même
enfin on aura un peu plus de soleil à
plus de clarté comme ces grands trous et
des est-ce que vous en pensez ça vous
plaît ou pas vous avez une opinion
on va sarkozy sera fait pour l'instant
sais pas encore ce que ça va donner
la transformation de la barre balzac
revient à 55 millions de francs
en 92 la réhabilitation de la cité des
4000 devraient être terminés au total ça
135 millions de francs
question les enfants des familles
d'origine qui veulent rester à la
courneuve
pourront-ils assumer l'augmentation des
loyers